hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts exploring the art behind
protein transfer I'm Julian child of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo fisher scientific thermo fisher
scientific is the world leader in
serving science a mission is to enable
our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer we help our
customers accelerate like science
research soft complex analytic akkallan
jizz improve patient diagnostics and
increase laboratory productivity through
premier brands thermo fisher scientific
applied biosystems intro gen III
scientific and unity lab services we
offer an unmatched combination of
innovative technologies purchasing
convenience and comprehensive support
for more information please visit
www.der malicious com we have a few
final episodes before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the events you could submit
questions by typing them into the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or to make
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speaker emily
problems and I Coplin is a product
manager for protein detection regions
and systems in the bio sciences division
of thermo fisher scientific she joined
the team in early 2015 coming from an
academic background in biological
sciences and a product management career
in the healthcare industry she currently
manages a range of products including
western blotting regions and kits
protein quantification of phase and SI
development region
I will now turn it over to Emily goblins
on presentation thank you so much for
that introduction and good morning to
everyone who's joining today again my
name is emily kaplan and i'm the product
manager of the protein detection
portfolio here at thermo fisher
scientific today we'll be discussing the
various technologies used for western
trance protein transfer in western
blotting as a general overview of what
we'll be discussing today we'll start
with the general definition of protein
transfer and see how it fits within the
western blotting workflow we'll talk
through the factors to consider before
choosing which method of protein
transfer is best to use and go through
each technique and available system we
will wrap up the presentation with
post-transfer considerations and tips
and tricks for successful western
blotting transfers western blotting
Western blotting is a widely used and
highly trusted an established method
used to detect the specific and targeted
proteins in the sample it begins by
using gel electrophoresis to separate
the proteins based on their molecular
weights post electrophoresis the
proteins are transferred or blotted from
the gel matrix to a membrane upon which
they are probed with antibodies and
detected by a chromogenic color metric
or fluorescent detection reagents the
end result is a detectable signal that
captures the protein of interest the
transfer step of the Western workflow is
integral to the success and outcome of
the detection of the target protein over
13 million gels are run each year in the
US and Europe alone and over 75 percent
of these gels are used in western
blotting applications the most
traditional form of transfer is done in
a wet tank environment however over the
most recent years significant
investments have been placed to improve
the time and maintain the effective
of the transfer step when choosing the
right transfer system there are many
considerations to contemplate some of
these decisions include the convenience
of a premade stack verse the flexibility
of assembling one's own stack materials
needed to just buffers and membranes and
the speed and time impact of the
transfer itself at a high level the
first factor is between traditional wet
tank transfer or the use of a fast
transfer device various devices have
been introduced over the years that
offer a reduction in total transfer time
available consumables of pre-made stacks
can additionally improve consistency and
throughput of your Western blots however
there is a price associated with fast
dry or semi dry transfer and this time
savings is key to determine whether this
is significant to your lab the next
component to evaluate is a type of
membrane in which you use nitrocellulose
and PDF are the two most commonly used
membranes these membranes are typically
unveiled available in either sheets or
rolls for wet and semi dry transfers or
within pre-made stacks offering the very
highest level of convenience
nitrocellulose and PDF membranes
commonly have a thickness of 100
micrometers with typical pore size of
point2 or point 4 5 micrometers most
proteins can successfully be blotted
using a point 45 pore size membrane
while 0.2 or even 0.1 pore size
membranes can be recommended for low
molecular weight proteins or peptides
less than 20 kilo dalton filter paper or
blotting paper and transfer buffers are
additional components needed to
facilitate the transfer from gel to
membrane traditional transfer buffers
contain hazardous material of methanol
however new fast transfer systems can
include a methanol free
a transfer buffer such as the one-step
transfer buffer used in the fast
semi-dry transfer the most commonly used
transfer technology is electro blotting
which uses an electric current to pull
the proteins from the page gel onto the
membrane this method is used due to the
efficiency speed and quantitative
aspects in general there are two primary
types of electro blotting traditional
wet tank transfer and rapid dry or semi
dry transfer the first method wet paint
transfer uses an external power supply
and is run at 4 degrees C or often on
ice to keep the temperature cooled over
the one hour to overnight time period
the latter method utilizes a device with
internal power supply and can transfer
the total protein in less than 10
minutes the transfer buffer is
incorporated into the transfer stacks
for the dry transfer system making this
a buffer list system nitrocellulose and
PVDF membranes are used due to their
large surface area to volume ratio each
of these however has various features
that provide different benefits to your
system PVDF membranes have a high
binding affinity for proteins and
nucleic acids but they must be pre
wetted with methanol or SML prior to
submerging into the transfer buffer
these membranes also provide better
retention of absorb proteins because of
the greater hydrophobicity and are less
brittle than nitrocellulose membrane
conversely nitrocellulose membranes are
a popular matrix because of their high
protein binding affinity and their
compatibility with various detection
methods nitrocellulose membranes do not
need the additional prewedding of
methanol or ethanol prior to used in the
transfer buffer
however these membranes can be fragile
and dry and more prone to breaking let's
talk about traditional wet tank transfer
wet paint transfer involves a series of
steps to set up prior to running the gel
to membrane transfer the first step seen
here is to prepare the transfer buffer
triste icing buffer with methanol is the
most commonly used choice for wet
transfer the buffer should be stored and
used at 4 degrees C next is important to
Aquila equilibrates the gel and membrane
by placing both in a tray containing 25
to 50 ml of the transfer buffer for
roughly 10 to 15 minutes with gentle
agitation next is the Assembly of the
gel membrane sandwich what two sheets of
filter paper and transfer the membrane
and transfer cassette pads with the
transfer buffer by submerging them
briefly when using your PVDF membrane
it's important to submerge that membrane
in a hundred percent methanol for about
30 seconds prior to placing it into the
transfer buffer the gel must be on the
cathode side relative to the membrane
when assembling the gel sandwich it's
important to avoid air bubbles between
any of the layers as this can result in
incomplete or uneven transfer load the
cassette and and connect it to an
external power supply small molecular
weight proteins tend to pass through the
membrane more readily and may require
shorter transfer time apply the
appropriate transfer time and powered
power setting to run the transfer what
King transfers the most commonly used
transfer method however it does require
additional setup time and the use of a
methanol based transfer buffer which is
a toxic and hazardous material needing
special disposal when performing a wet
transfer
gels are electro transferred at either a
constant current or constant voltage
from as little as one hour up to
overnight transfers are typically
performed at four degrees C to mitigate
the heat produced and maybe run on an
ice pack for further cooling the
transfer efficiency improves with
increased transfer time and is better
and often needed for high molecular
weight proteins with increasing time
there is a risk of over transfer of the
proteins through the membrane causing
stripping or blowing out this can be
seen in particular with low molecular
weight proteins when using membranes
with a larger pore size for this reason
smaller pore size membranes are often
used with low molecular weight proteins
the primary issue with wet paint
transfer is the use and handling of
hazzard ethanol-based transfer buffer to
combat this issue invitrogen mini blot
module was designed to use two to four
times less methanol based transfer
buffer than other comparable transfer
modules just imagine handling less and
spilling rest of that methanol based
transfer the leak free and robust is
device incorporates a fitted gasket for
improved sealing the robust electrode
can optimize protein transfer in as
little as 30 to 60 minutes semi-dry
blotting for some I Drive protein
transfer the transfer sandwich is placed
horizontally between two plate
electrodes in a cement dry transfer
apparatus the speed of the transfer is
improved by maximizing the current
passing through the gel instead of
around the gel as seen in wet pink
transfer to accomplish this the amount
of buffer available during the transfer
is limited to that what is which is
contained in the sandwich the filter
paper used should be cut to
the exact dimensions of the gel and it's
often beneficial to use extra stick
filter paper for high molecular weights
as it can hold more transfer buffer the
length of time the traditional wet tank
transfer can require is greatly reduced
by the use of a rapid semi-dry
transferred device the Pierce power
blotter incorporates the bit the ability
to transfer one to two midi gels or 12
for mini Giles on a single cassette use
of the one-step transfer buffer also
reduces the transfer time down to less
than 10 minutes and eliminates the use
of any methanol based transfer buffers
the system also uses an integrated power
supply and reduces the need to hook up
to an external power supply this
produces high efficiency protein
transfer across a broad range of protein
sizes data seen here shows the protein
transfer efficiency of tank transfer
over 16 hours compared to the peers
power blotter in 10 minutes h8 egg
protein expressed Nicole I was purified
using an tha magnetic beads samples were
prepared and run in an SDS gel
subsequently transferred to a
nitrocellulose membrane efficiency of
the tank transfer with use of Tobin
buffer over 16 hours is compared to the
peers power bladder using the one-step
transfer buffer in 10 minutes membranes
were probed with an tha antibody washed
and probed with goat anti-mouse hrp
washed and finally incubated in the
super signal West's offensive
chemiluminescence substrate here you can
see the image captured show in the
comparison of these two systems the
image was captured on the thermo
scientific my field imager and band
densitometry was determined and animal
using the my CL analysis software
results from the experiments show an
increased intensity per well up to two
times from the lysate end of all
anti-hiv magnetic bead volumes
the Pierce power plotter is a fast
efficient transfer device that offers a
great reduction in time compared to wet
tank transfer the other benefit of this
system is it's flexible and open system
allowing for the high throughput of four
mini blots or to MIDI blots high protein
transfer efficiency can be realized over
a variety of protein sizes with the
added convenience of a pre program
method to run either low medium or high
molecular weights in addition to
creating customized proteins dry
transfer dry electro blotting provides
the highest level of convenience in fast
transfer devices the buffer ion
reservoirs are incorporated into the gel
matrix or the transfer stacks instead of
a buffer tank or so papers the high
ionic density of the gel matrix enables
the rapid protein transfer and provides
consistency and control a reduction in
preparation time runtime and cleanup
time is the ultimate benefit of the dry
system what an semi-dry protein transfer
methods require the setup of the gel
membrane stack and cleanup of either the
cassette or the transfer tinks adding
time and possible variability to the
transfer stage the NB trogen I blot to
system provides reduced hands on time
and improves the user efficiency that
allows for a high throughput of gel to
membrane transfers the premade
consumable stacks are designed to be
intuitive simple and convenient and
leaves no liquid clean up to post
transfer the system is similar to the
semi dry device in offering both program
settings to simplify the transfer method
or allowing custom programs to fit any
unique
need data shown here shows the strong
performance of the I bought two system
regardless of gel chemistry serial
dilutions of phosphorylated EGF receptor
was run on three different gel types the
both four to twelve percent mistress new
page fourth 12 percentage trees and four
to twenty percent truth glycine the
proteins were then transferred using the
I blot to device and transferred to
either PVDF or nitrocellulose membrane
stacks post transfer these membranes
were probed with phospho EGF mouse
antibody washed and then probe
anti-mouse hrp these blots were
incubated in the Novak CCL
chemiluminescence substrate and high
performance can be visualized across the
sixth system additionally transfer
efficiency followed by the near-ir
detection of fluorescently labeled
secondaries on both nitrocellulose and
PVDF membranes in the 700 and 800 nir
channels can be visualized post used of
the i plot to device additionally we
show the combination of the 700 and 800
channel with an overlay of these two
targets clear and sharp bands of both
the protein ladder and the target
protein are detected after this dry
system transfer they are easily
distinguished using the fluorescent
detection systems and Chris bands are
detected Chris bands are important for
detection and I blot to cleanly transfer
without the blowout or smudging the I
blot to blotting device provides fast
reliable protein transfer efficiency in
a user-friendly and highly convenient
format it is a buffer free system
also offers ready-to-use stacks in both
mini and mini size gels and both for
nitrocellulose or PVDF membranes the
system is capable of high turnover and
throughput due to the easily and non
cleanup setup of the I blot to device it
also has the ability to run one MIDI or
two mini Giles per transfer when
evaluating what system is most
beneficial to you it's important to wait
the differences between each method this
includes the convenience time throughput
and price the first difference is in
convenience convenience in high
throughput capacity our benefits of the
I blot to and power blotter devices
however the I bought two can transfer
only one MIDI or two mini sized gels
while the power blotter can transfer
double that capacity on a single
cassette what tank transfer allows
larger amounts of methanol based
transfer buffer to be used but can offer
flexibility on the number of gels run
per transfer the I blot 2 provides a
buffer free setup and no clean up the
power blotter can can double the
capacity of the I blot to device but
does require the use of the one-step
transfer buffer for rapid transfer the
second difference is in the use of
consumables
I plot to offers pre-made transfer
stacks which can offer consistency and
less hands-on time no more building your
own transfer sandwich the peers power
bladder and wet tank transfer require a
build your own stack setup but they do
have the ability to use different
buffers and stack materials to fit an
individual's needs price is always a
consideration as well and the last
consideration here with high convenience
comes a higher price and this
convenience resonates with many
high-throughput labs in its ability to
speed up time and increase increase
reproducibility within the lab for
cost-conscious labs however the open
system of the power plotter or a wet
tank transfer may be may continue to be
the most appropriate option
the value for time continuum can be
visualized here when it comes to the
comparison of wet semi-dry rapid to my
dry and drive lighting systems
traditional tank transfer can take up to
one hour to overnight run at 4 degrees C
or on an ice pack to reduce the heat the
rapid semi dry or dry transfer systems
offer transfer in less than 10 minutes
the total time compared between the dry
transfer system rapid semi dry and wet
transfer can be visualized here again
with less time comes a greater cost in
the amount of the consumables and the
need for a device to be run for ultimate
convenience in a time reduction the I
blot to dry system is most appropriate
post-transfer many times it is desired
to check the efficiency of the transfer
stating the gel post transfer is often
used as a way to confirm the complete
transfer of proteins however steaming
the gel is unreliable as it does not
indicate how well the proteins
transferred to the membrane a more
effective way to monitor transfer
efficiency is to stain the membrane with
a reversible stain concho s is a widely
used stain however it has limited
sensitivity and can fade quickly making
it difficult to document the pierced
reversible protein stain from thermo
fisher scientific is more sensitive
easier to document and is permanent
until it's removed it also has a lower
limit of detection over five times more
sensitive than the traditional poncho s
stain the Pierce reversible stain is
safe simple and has a quick protocol
that results in a turquoise blue band in
less than five minutes the stain can be
removed in under 15 min
and further can be stored at room
temperature saving precious refrigerator
space and eliminating the need to
equilibrate prior to use the bottom
right of this slide shows you a
comparison of the Pierce reversible
stain and the poncho s stain the data
here shows the benefits of the piers
reversible stain over the traditional
poncho s data to the right shows the
comparison of these stains on PVDF
membrane the Pierce unstained protein
molecular weight marker was serial
diluted and run in lanes 1 through 9 the
four to twenty percent revised in
sds-page gel was run and followed by
blotting to a PVDF membrane lot a was
stained with the Pierce reversible stain
and block B was stained with the poncho
s
you can see significantly better
staining with the Pierce reversible seen
over the poncho s high background is one
of the most common issues scientists
face post transferred during Western
blot detection background can be can be
seen regardless of the protein transfer
method and is primarily due to poor
quality primary antibodies before
blocking reagent such as the super
signal Western blot enhancer can be used
to improve the signal and reduce the
background of your Western blot using
the super signal Western blot enhancer
can allow you to achieve three to ten
fold better signal intensity and
sensitivity compared to detection
performed without this reagent for
difficult to detect proteins or low
affinity antibodies the super signal
Western blot enhancer reagent can
improve the signal-to-noise ratio and
enhance your specificity it does this in
two ways first the enhancer helps to
expose the epitopes in order to enable
better binding it also promotes specific
binding to the target protein by
increasing the ionic strength so that
nonspecific binding falls out even with
high promiscuous antibodies that bind to
anything you can get great results using
this product
the data shown here uses cell lysate
loaded and run on sds-page gel at 1.25
two point five five and ten micrograms
per Lane transferred to a nitrocellulose
membrane and probed using protocols both
with and without the use of super signal
Western blot enhancer here on the Left
we can see super signal Western blot
enhancer helps to enable the detection
of very low abundant targets on the
right we see a similar effect using the
super signal Western blot enhancer and
its ability to improve the lower limit
of detection for the chemiluminescence
substrate
protein transfer tips and tricks the
overall transfer efficiency and
variability and electro blotting methods
is dependent upon the protein size and
charge gel type membrane type transfer
buffer composition time transfer
temperature number of gels and a list
goes on when a protein transfer does not
work the desired standard there can be
many different factors at play some
helpful tips to help get the desired
results that you want is to look at your
low to look at your SDS and methanol and
decide to use high-grade methanol MSDS
low quality SDS or methanol can generate
background and increased conductivity
resulting in poor protein transfer SDS
coats the protein to allow transfer
increasing your sgs4 large molecular
weight proteins and removing SDS for
small molecular weight proteins can help
with the transfer methanol removes
residual SDS from proteins decreasing
the amount of methanol to less than ten
percent for large molecular weight
proteins and increasing for small
molecular weight proteins can help
achieve better transfer when determining
the protein transfer efficiency a semi
dry or dry protein transfer regardless
the technique used some proteins may
remain in the gel post-transfer gels are
often more than ten times as thick as
the membrane and thus can hold large
amounts of volume and protein complete
transfer out of the challenge into the
membrane of every protein is not always
possible what tank transfer provides a
buffer or wet environment system
allowing transfer around the jaw semi
dry and dry transfer systems force the
movement directly through the mate
trick additionally staining up the gel
is not a precise reflection of the
transfer efficiency but rather
reversible membrane stain should be used
to determine the effectiveness of the
protein transfer when transferring high
molecular weight proteins high or broad
range pre-stained protein ladders
provide an inaccurate assessment on the
unstained target protein transfer
covalently attached hydrophobic dies
affect the charge of the recombinant
protein of the protein ladder thereby
affecting the binding capacity and
transfer efficiency of your pre-stained
ladder this is particularly noticeable
in four to twenty percent triz glycine
ladders however when transferring high
molecular weight proteins on a fast
transfer device additional time or
voltage may be needed to completely
transfer the large molecular weight
proteins out of the gel and into the
membrane despite popular belief rapid
transfer systems can equally be as
effective of transferring high molecular
weight proteins from the gel to the
membrane this can be seen on the right
hand side of the slide EGFR mtor and ECM
29 all have molecular weights that are
greater than 190 kilodaltons these
proteins were transferred with the peers
power blotter and wet tank transfer both
were evaluated by staining the membranes
post transfer as well as completing the
Western blot results you can see similar
if not better transfer efficiency using
the rapids to my do I transfer device as
opposed to Wetpaint transfer
today we covered many details around the
primary transfer methods for Western
blotting each method has its own benefit
whether it be convenience consistency
price or time it's important to evaluate
the need of the individual lab to assess
which method is best for your needs
thermo fisher scientific offer solutions
and products to fit the needs for
customers across many areas of protein
biology at this point we can open up for
any question
great so thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session if you
remind our audience on how to submit
wish you can submit questions like
having an insta Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button it's a role enough for the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can our first
question for take transfer what is the
bet what is better for a transfer
process ethanol or methanol so either
ethanol or methanol can be used in the
transfer buffer methanol is toxic so you
will need to be careful using it but
analytical grade methanol has to be used
due to the impurities that methanol can
cause and protein transfer issues so in
effect either is available to be used at
keeping in mind that methanol should be
used at a high analytical grade how much
methodol is used in the transfer buffer
typically you'll see up to twenty
percent of methanol or ethanol used in
the transfer buffer methanol is used to
help a small molecular weight protein
transfers some devices though such as
the power bladder or I bought two device
allow transfer without the use of
hazardous methanol the one-step transfer
buffer used in the power bladder is
methanol free and therefore not toxic as
methanol is well it's usually has SDS to
the transcript a third interview with
protein to answer SDS is commonly used
for helping large molecular weight
proteins transfer effectively you can
use up to the point zero five percent in
the buffer to help increase the transfer
efficiency for large molecular weight
proteins okay so we do not have time for
any more questions
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing until j28 2070 I would
like to once again think I'm the Goblin
for presentation do you have any final
comments again thank you for the time
today please take full advantage of the
resources that thermo Fisher does
provide on transfers as well as our full
western blotting technical guides I
thank you for the time and I appreciate
the attention hey you will receive an
email from labret letting you in this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to follow this announcement
to your colleagues madness today's live
events see you next time and goodbye